[Applause]
let's talk about
Taiwan and the Taiwan
straet because for the last few years
these Waters haven't exactly been calm
this is unprecedented in the air and at
Sea Taiwan is surrounded 12 Chinese
fighter jets Crossing median line off
the Taiwan straet with Taiwan caught in
a kind of tug of war between the US and
China there are fears about where this
could all end up of course that's the
million dooll question that everyone
wants to know so why is Taiwan such a
flasho between two of the world's
biggest
Powers Taiwan is an island stuck in a
kind of political limbo it's a
democratic self-governing territory just
over the water is China which claims
Taiwan as its own but many Taiwanese
take issue with that then you add in the
us which has taken on the role of
neighborhood cop and you end up with
Taiwan as the focus for many big
competing interests but to understand
how we got here you have to know the
backstory Taiwan was ruled by Imperial
China for 20000 years then Japan had it
for 50 years after winning a war against
China but when Japan lost in World War
II China One of the victors got Taiwan
back again then you had the Chinese
Civil War now's D's Communist forces
took over the mainland while the other
side the nationalist forces of changai
Sheek escaped to
Taiwan so in 1949 China sort of split in
two and you had two rival governments
one in Taiwan one in Beijing both
claiming they were the true government
of China the side in Taiwan was known as
the Republic of China The Roc and that's
still the Island's official name today
and on the mainland the Communist Party
declared a brand new Chinese State the
People's Republic of China PRC for short
now remember the US wasn't exactly a fan
of Communism and so it was the ROC in
Taiwan that mostly got the international
recognition including a seat at the UN
but by the 1970s that seat didn't really
make sense anymore the UN passed a
resolution confirming the
representatives from the PRC as the only
lawful representatives of China CH to
the United Nations and so the ROC was
out we are been deserted we are been
forsaken so what does all this mean for
taiwan's political status today well it
leaves it in that limbo we talked about
at the beginning now from beijing's
perspective it's pretty clear China is
one country and Taiwan is part of it
right now the island governs itself but
beijing's position is that eventually
it'll be reunited with the
mainland
so what about taiwan's status according
to Taiwan well it depends who's in power
over the years political parties have
taken different positions some have been
slightly more
pro-china others have been more
pro-independence
but even those parties have been careful
about explicitly pushing for full
sovereignty most have referred to kind
of fudge it because that's what the
Taiwanese people seem to
prefer if we consider what exactly this
political spectrum that Taiwanese voters
Place themselves on uh we have one long
line where on one end you have immediate
unification with the PRC and on the
other end you have immediate
Independence as the Republic of Taiwan
and in the middle you have what we
describe as the status quo and we know
from Decades of public opinion research
that Taiwanese voters do not want either
extreme the majority of Taiwanese voters
want the status quo Taiwanese people
don't love this very awkward Gray Zone
that they exist in but it's a choice of
pragmatism where they know that any
radical change could lead to War uh and
Taiwanese voters do not want war okay so
what about the US well their position is
also a bit of a fudge it even has an
official name strategic ambiguity on the
one hand they do acknowledge that Taiwan
is a part of China and not an
independent country there's no official
US Embassy in Taipei for example but on
the other hand they sort of want China
to leave Taiwan alone and one form of
deterrence is making sure Taiwan is well
armed the US already sells Taiwan a lot
of weapons and recently gave $80 million
in military aid what the United States
rejects is either side unilaterally
changing the Status Quo on one hand it
tells Taiwan that if it unilaterally
declares independence the United United
States is less likely to support Taiwan
if the PRC attacks on the other hand uh
if the PRC attacks Taiwan unprovoked
then the United States is very likely to
defend Taiwan because that's the PRC
unilaterally changing the Status Quo
When Donald Trump was in power he got
Cozier with Taiwan than previous US
presidents some argue President Biden
has gone even further at times he seems
to have been pretty unambiguous about
backing Taiwan are you willing to get
involved milit to defend Taiwan if it
comes to that yes you
are that's the commitment we
made China condemned that comment and
Biden said later that it didn't
represent any actual change of that US
policy of strategic ambiguity but things
escalated again when then us house
Speaker Nancy Pelosi visited Taiwan the
most senior us politician to visit
Taiwan in 25 years an American this
senior on this soil is
provocative across the narrow Taiwan
straight China responded announcing new
live fire military drills and circling
Taiwan there's definitely been a change
in the nature of PC threats towards
Taiwan ever since Nancy Pelosi's visit
here uh the quantity of fighter jets
that fly into taiwan's air defense
identification Zone has has increased
drastically they now pass the so-called
median line between uh Taiwan and the
PRC and there starting to use way more
uh serious spider jets that could really
do damage if they were into to enter
into a conflict so that's the big
picture if things spin out of control we
could potentially be talking about a war
between the US and China it means that
when things are tense around Taiwan it's
a big
deal it's also why a lot of people will
be watching Taiwan in
2024 in January Taiwanese voters will
elect a new president who will help
determine the next chapter in how it
deals with China
but some argue the US presidential
election in November is the one that
will really set the tone I think we
actually need to wait till after the
November election in the United States
to really understand what the meaning is
for taiwan's next president because how
the Taiwan relationship with the United
States will change if uh Donald Trump
for example is reelected I think is
going to be radically different than how
taiwan's relationship is under Joe
[Music]
Biden